what is going on there reject nation
greg and john here today we are going to
watch the official trailer for
snake guys if you guys didn't catch our
reaction to the teaser we actually did
an
interview with henry golding that i
think you guys would really enjoy it's a
really fun one play a snake guys case
you guys didn't know we are going to
shoot this on the day
that the trailer has debuted if this is
coming to you the day
after that is because there were
sections of the trailer that had to be
muted due to music
what i did not want to land us in is
having you guys
watch a reaction where we're muted and
the trailers muted as well so the best
thing we could do
is wait for the youtube detector to tell
us when
those parts are copyright claimed and
then we could just lower the
audio track of the trailer itself and we
don't have to be muted that way it's not
so jarring of an experience to watch i
think it's a little bit better
that way versus the other way if this
part of the video is here that means
this is going up the next day this is
just a backup for us right now either
way i've heard some really great things
about the trailer
let's see what's in store
nice nice
so gritty
andrew koji this man be sure to trust
let's go let's go yes yes
that's cool awesome
yeah you do
cool cool oh
cool
[Music]
scarlet
awesome i feel following you for some
time
cool
[Laughter]
nice
[Music]
man it does look awesome badass
and badass nice same guys be talking all
over this trailer
that's right man that's that's that's
the true nature of this character
because
everyone was quick to point out on the
teaser what you did do a good job doing
is when a character showed up you said
their name
their character name so that way it
appeared like you really knew
the gi joe characters yeah i love their
comics written by larry hamas very
impressive
this is my favorite scoreless series
storm shadow
this is a good it's a good meta reaction
i didn't call it
grand master now see now you're just
showing you say i said heart
master and i was like you got it wrong
no hardman no i know i grabbed that's
a different one yeah you guys what i was
thinking
anyway now you're right there's another
master though that's not hard
yes yes yes yes
trailer it's a great trailer yeah i love
the action it looks very
practical stunt oriented and it's nice
to have a movie in a world like this
gi joe you know big action spectacle
blockbuster that looks like a tangible
you know martial arts fight movie too
well yeah they made it just a hardcore
asian martial arts flick with a couple
of people who are not asian
in front of the camera here it seems
that you have two different camps that
are happening with the gi joe audience
right now you have
one audience who really is opposed
against this
believe me i've heard it there are
people who don't like this reinvention
they think there's like what's the
what's the word they hate with virtue
signaling is the word i'm constantly
hearing oh yeah they turned a white
character into an asian character yeah
what the hell and then they also made
him
you know look like henry goldman not
disfigured or anything like that
yeah takes his mask off pretty great
it's every it's everything that goes
against you
and then the other camp the embrace of
asian representation and i have my
asian pride involved in the mix too i'm
not completely biased towards that
there's just like
other little camp here uh that you might
not be aware of
which are people who are not that
invested in gi joe
there are people like john and i who are
not the biggest gi joe enthusiast you
know
gi joe is not something that i quite
particularly grew up on it was more of
just this casual thing that was sort of
happening in the background
and i wasn't ever really attached to it
too much so i don't really have a dog in
any particular fight here i can just go
off of what we're seeing so far and what
we're seeing so far looks like just a
very solid action flick i cannot speak
for the voice of the people who are
upset
over whatever they have changed and
there are some people who i know have
warmed up to this
so far but as we're standing here henry
golden looks solid
koji looks great uh ecowise i'm always
excited to see him kind of cool when
you're like flashing to some raid fight
scenes and you've got eco aways here
it looks shot well like this looks like
a fun movie this looks like a fun
action adventure flick where i can get
on board with henry golding and snake
guys
because i don't really have a prior
attachment to snake eyes or then he was
a mysterious badass who i preferred
watching
usually more than any other gi joe
character that's as far as it goes i
think this is really rad
and i don't uh i don't succumb to the
side that
has a the controversy yeah well yeah and
i don't know i feel like as long as they
make
good use of that mask and they keep him
in it at least a good amount of part
of the time and if as long as they use
it substantially i feel like there could
be a bridge
to those fans as well because too i mean
you know on the big screen
the previous gi joe films aren't the
most beloved g.i joe properties out
there and i feel like you could split
the difference some because also too i
mean if you're into gi joe i have to
imagine that you probably
would also appreciate some really
top-notch action
set pieces that are done with as much
gusto as it appears like these are i
mean this does look
convincingly like you know a martial
arts
ninja epic as much as there are you know
certain things with guns and more modern
fighting tactics and whatnot like this
does look
you know pretty at least spiritually
akin to that world
anyway so i don't know yeah just as an
action movie lover this looks pretty
cool to me
i am yeah i feel like he'll probably
take the vows silence path by the end of
the movie but if they want to keep this
going as a franchise it might keep snake
eyes talking
speaking all over this trailer so i i
wonder how that will bode
most with audiences i think that's
probably like the the one thing that i'm
most curious about because i was down
for a silent character throughout but
we'll see all right guys so leave your
thoughts down below sorry i forgot this
to you a little bit late either
way subscribe click that bell hit that
like button
and hey we'll catch you guys soon